the winter season means a variety of
blockbuster family and oscar-worthy
movies will be hitting the big screen
and I'm here to give you a quick rundown
of what's coming out in this month so
you can plan ahead on what you want to
see all I got to do the thing this is
your weekend ticket December preview
[Music]
the toy said some of us had as a kid
comes to life as a girl has turned into
a minifigure and transported to the
world of Playmobil in search of her lost
brother pink lego movie vibes in this
family-friendly movie well play a
college campus becomes a dangerous
nightmare in black Christmas as most
students have gone home leaving a
handful of sorority girls to face a
slasher for slashers picking off
students one by one this is a Blum House
production so expect their signature
horror scares and things like someone
getting stabbed by an icicle based on a
true story Richard Jewell tells the
story of a security guard who finds a
bomb at the 1996 Olympics and
successfully evacuated the area while
he's deemed a hero his life changes he's
also accused of being a suspect you
always look at the guy who found the
bomb just like he was with a guy found
the body
Jules fits the profile of the lone
bomber the film is directed by Clint
Eastwood so if you like his past movies
you'll probably like this one in the
sequel Jumanji the next level there are
new players in the game as a couple of
old men get sucked into Jumanji with the
kids and everyone takes over different
avatar bodies this time the rock has to
do a Danny DeVito impression that'll
probably nod you forward into putting
this one on your list would you look at
me I haven't looked like this since
never you look like this never I think
my eyes are a different color all of you
is it different color bombshell revisits
the rise of a handful of female
reporters in a masculine controlled
media culture and one woman's fight to
bring awareness to the disparities you
might not want to miss this
groundbreaking story being told through
a list hack ask yourself what would
scare my grandmother or piss off my
grandfather and that's a fox story mhm
thanks the Broadway musical Cats is
retold through a mix of live-action and
CG where we are introduced to an alley
way of singing dancing cats just trying
to make a living on the streets
hey that's Taylor Swift as a cat are you
doing their three Peele
taking one last look sir my friends Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker is said to be
the last in the nine film Skywalker saga
we see Rey and the remaining resistance
face off against kylo Ren once more as
well as some much hinted at surprises
including the possible return of Emperor
Palpatine in another serious role for
Adam Sandler a jeweler's gambling habits
have put his life into all sorts of
danger and pushed him to frantically
keep it together and keep his family
safe
all I know is I want that diamond
encrusted Furby for Christmas as a
Christmas bonus from Fandango that's my
Christmas wish and another family
offering spies in the sky seize a spy go
perhaps to deep undercover as he's
turned into a pigeon and must now work
with a young scientist to complete a
mission I could see my butt and your
face at the same time that is so cool
and this adaptation of the classic novel
Little Women follows the Mark sisters as
they come of age in the aftermath of the
Civil War
this version is directed by Greta Gerwig
who made ladybird another coming-of-age
movie so it seems like a perfect fit
making short and spicy and if the main
character is a girl make sure she's
married by the end in a retelling of a
story called the director Sam Mendes by
his grandfather 1917 is the tale of two
British soldiers tasked with the mission
of delivering vital information of an
upcoming ambush across dangerous
territory in World War one there's only
one way this ends
Last Man Standing a young yet driven
lawyer takes on a volatile case and just
mercy his challenge is to defend a man
wrongfully accused of murdering an
eighteen year old girl in 1987 Alabama
and I'm gonna do everything possible to
keep them from taking you all know what
you into down here and Alabama when you
get it from the moment you're born got
mr. McMillan we don't you that is your
weekend ticket December preview let us
know in the comments which movies you'll
be seeing this holiday season oh my god
it were the perfect jacket for the
[Music]